i think you should start with a four-day
work week
because you you don't have a lot of
advantages over the big companies
and
most research that i can find support
that before they work week will make
people more productive
and having that extra day off can
attract
talent
from big companies and it will be very
hard for them to compete with that
aspect welcome to 20 minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders and hello
shai pele director of software
engineering at new relic for applied
intelligence
chai started his career at the israeli
intelligence corps as a software
developer and team leader he continued
working in cyber security while
completing a bsc in mathematics and
philosophy
he then served four years as a founder
and cto for the 20-person startup omg
wen which created a global search and
personalization engine for leisure
events
next shai worked at wix.com as a
frontend staff engineer
he completed an mba at ie university in
madrid before joining new relic
shai pelig welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today
excellent thank you very excited my
thank you video
well okay well this is going to be a
huge honor i'm honored that you chose me
as your first vic
host
to get to know you in these next 20
minutes or so today your director of
engineering and new relic you've
previously held
senior positions in the engineering
department
on startup previously in the idea of
intelligence core
so overall you know a wide array of
experiences throughout your career and
what i'd love to do in these 20 minutes
big milestones in your career your both
your personal experience but also what
you learned professionally that you took
with you as you as you continued
advancing so shy maybe take me back
and share with your entrance to the tech
world to computer science and then we'll
move from there
okay i was lucky because my father was
in the business we're gonna go way back
and he got me some tutorials and books
and that's how i started programming
and i was even more lucky that he got me
my first job
during high school so by the time i got
to the army to the 8200 i had some
knowledge about programming i was sure i
had a lot of knowledge which proved to
be not correct
but spending four years there in that
unit where i met most of my
best friends even to this day
18 years later
was probably the best job i ever
held even though they didn't pay a lot
oh
right now tell me a little bit about
coming into 8200 after having worked in
high school when you mentioned that you
you
it turned out you realize you didn't how
did that how did that tangibly feel or
how did you experience that
when i got there
the person i was replacing was just
leaving and
yeah so i i got his system that he wrote
alone it was a production system and
they tell you if anything is not working
our security
is at risk the country is at risk
and then it's not working and you have
not
being in charge of systems that seem
critical
and
when you
when you bump into a problem you have to
fix it
mostly yourself
so
that was a very special way to learn
how to be a developer and then a team
leader
out of pressure out of the feeling of
saving your country which i i don't
really believe today but then as a young
kid
and i bought it
and the most significant part was being
surrounded by similar people that were
doing the same things and started our
group of friends
where
like 50 fans even today
wow keeping very close closely in touch
and that's the shelter i have here and
that's my bubble and what makes me feel
safe
and be myself
incredible and
yeah
and and you know for those little things
that don't necessarily know how the unit
works
you know you mentioning that this is the
most amazing job you've ever held
considering that you're working in some
of the most exciting companies in the
israel ecosystem which is just bursting
and
great time there as well but but this
idea that you're reflecting back on your
army service in 8200 with the
understanding that this was a very
special time because of the people that
surrounded you and
helped you grow i think that's pretty
meaningful
yes it is um
yeah that was i was lucky because i
i i'm not the army material it's very
hard to be for me to be locked in places
and being told what to do and what to
wear
but luckily the people there and my
commanding officers were very reasonable
people from the industry amazing and
they they cared about people not about
all the army nonsense
i got on trials 18 times
and survived
being in the army and it turned out to
be a good period even though it was it
would have gone on really easily would
have left
sure yeah now as as you were leaving
your service
which was not you know simply
if i believe you said a little bit more
than four years
um
yeah
what did you take with you
as you entered the job market what you
know either personally professionally
what what really did you take with you
from that experience
i was very confident in myself i was
cocky and arrogant it took me a while to
get over that
and
really getting out of those four years i
was sure i was one of the best in the
world and any place would be lucky to
get me and i chose my places carefully
as well as a confident leader
and it took me a while because i'm
better at being a person
how is it uh how is it was it bad for me
i believe yeah how did that actually
come to pass on
nobody likes uh arrogance
and cockiness
by working with other people
and
the relationships in my life
and luckily
i had my friends the same group of
friends and
we go together
and we learn to become better people and
to put others before ourselves
and then the important part of any
relationship is
the friendship part
and
over the years it helped me realize that
everything every friend every
relationship that they make
it's supposed to be for for life
so
that the people that you surround
yourself with with people you never want
to push away
right
now it does help to be confident in
getting things and pursuing dreams
and in negotiating negotiating
so there are advantages
but you can be self-confident without
being organ
what was this understanding
was this a
you know a momentary understanding that
in in an instance you understood wait a
second i've been
prac
not being the person that i want to be
was it a gradual thing that you know
over time you you you saw more and more
you started correcting yourself
because i think that that's it's a
really important thing to to discuss
especially today as
going around a lot of capital a lot of
success stories and it's very easy to
get locked up behind those stories and
you know feel above a lot a lot of
what's happening around the world
i believe it was gradual that i got some
feedback from people i trusted and
at some point i learned to look at
myself
and i also learned what i like about
other people
and being humble
when i met humble people and
i i
really like that i wanted to become that
even very very successful people
that are really humble about their
achievements
yeah right
yeah just getting
to know those experiences
i think it was a dodger
i need to select a little more
walk me walk me through your other your
other work experiences both
but also on the r d
and more senior roles within the
companies
so
after the army it was all about money
just going to work
they paid more because that was the
reverse of what you get in the army
that made me feel better
right i did that for a few years
outsourcing
for many companies different projects
from hospitals to
survival as well
and
after several years of that i went to
work for a cyber company
that doesn't exist today
and there i had another
learning
experience or self-reflecting experience
when i realized i worked for an evil
company
what do i mean by evil
the product that i made was sold to keep
dictators in power
for example wow they sold their love to
africa and and
i started to think about my life and
we each have talent
and i think it's such a waste
and
a time
to
give your talents away for the forces of
evil
where you can do something else
and i couldn't stand it anymore i
stopped
i
left that job and that entire field i
i find it hard to walk in places i don't
believe in the products
yeah ever since
which makes sense
and so after that i wanted to create
something that would help the world and
i started my
company
together and
so so i
interested into the entrepreneurial
world and starting a company is
one of the consequences of you being in
a place where you weren't doing
something meaningful for the world or on
the other
developing software that could
potentially harm the world
yeah that's one of the reasons another
reason is that i am ambitious
and
i want in my life to have success on the
world stage
i haven't uh
so far
but the journey just begins just
beginning now
and
also i like to create
it's very exciting
that's the entire development
engineering
programming world product world
you create
things that other people enjoy and use
and so those are my reasons
now
and i guess i also then i also really
wanted to succeed
financially still but
go through and an ipo or an exit or
something like that
and that's also a change for me today
that won't be my goal today
right
and so as
happening today with you know other
young young entrepreneurs or young teams
and companies
as a technology leader
in in a variety of companies what what
what did you learn about
you know by either leading the
technological side strategically or or
leading the people that are running the
technological side
i have i think i have some advice for
new companies new startups or new
entrepreneurs now
one of them
and i'm not sure it's gonna work but i'm
gonna try it next time i think you
should start with a four-day walk week
because you you don't have a lot of
advantages over the big companies
and
most research that i can find supports
that before they work week will make
people more productive
and having that extra day off can
attract
talent from
big companies and it will be very hard
for them to compete with that aspect
and for a while until they get they get
the point
yes so that's one advice
and the second advice
i would i would think about is
pick something that is a wealthy cause
help the world some somehow because the
best people
which are probably your friends
in other companies
they will need to leave places that are
very hard to live
will be
expensive for them the opportunity costs
lost that they will have from
by moving to a startup is huge
and so
they have to do it because they want
that thing to exist
it can't be
i can't imagine myself going to work for
a company that improves something in
payments
yeah
some optimization
purpose
yeah i'll go trading
but i can't
but some people enjoy other challenges
in that but i wouldn't think that
now is the do you find that the
engineering
hands-on work does that differ
between the high impact places and the
impact places i'm trying to figure out
you know how
you know how much does the company's
vision or their whatever they do
how much does it
potentially conflict with what you
want to be inspired by how much of that
is actually being translated into your
daily life rather than you know simply
through emails from the ceo through
videos etc
i'm not sure i understood the question
completely are you asking if in small
companies the engineering world is less
exciting
no i think i'm i'm wondering
much easier
you're mentioning it's important for you
to know that you're working on on on
something substantial um yes and
in the day-to-day work that you do do
you feel the
is the the
the product how how how much does it
actually come into play with what you
just developed for your decision making
as to where to go work is relevant you
know every hour of every day
yeah i think you should enjoy working on
the products and believe in the vision
of the company
every day it's not just
when you pick the company
the products you help build the talent
you put into things
give inform yourself to some
someone else to a company it should be
used to improve something
and
and it's not that hard to be a company
that improves the world i think wix
improves the world by giving small
businesses a way to compete
for example
and new relic my current company
improves the world by
keeping uh
getting software to be better more
reliable
and having less downtime and keeping
developers asleep at night
by having less incidents
right
there's a lot of
health companies that
are obviously helping
there are a lot of options it's not like
you are limiting yourself a lot by
choosing the correct form
you have to be interested in products
yeah so i wanted to know you a little
bit better and i want you to take me
back to your childhood okay and share
with me a little bit about you know
who you were and and what really
was a kid you know from a curiosity
perspective what really fascinated you
it's kind of weird
because the
starting
the military was such an impactful
event for me i don't have a lot of
childhood memories
it's like my life started a bit later
i
wanna ask me about school i remember i
really liked uh music lessons
and
i like playing outside with friends
depends on which school and which period
you're asking about
yeah
yeah just took me a while to find myself
and still finding myself but i believe i
became
shy
um
around mid-20s a bit later
and i find it hard to remember
high school
and
before that
let's be like very different person
and what if i were to ask you what
really inspires you today
in your daily life
um
is that
also around
role
models you'd say or about things i i see
um let's do the role model thing i i
think i really like billy eilish
compared to
other performers
when i was growing up
i think she
is inspirational and a good role model
for everyone she talks about
mental health a lot
and her songs are not panel
and she supports the point of this
what inspires me
my day-to-day life i think that my mba
experience which was one of the greatest
challenges and exciting times in my life
so just putting
everything on hold and going alone away
from that support system we talked about
and to a different country with a
different language
to meet a bunch of strangers
that was a hard experience
at the first several months i was crying
wow it became one of the best
experiences in my life
and
while there my priorities changed i
found that my
my love for people
and
friends and
co-workers and everyone i meet
and
it's turned into a love for management
so if i thought before the mba that i'm
gonna go into return and start another
company
doing that here
i realized that i want
if i i always i always try to better
myself to improve myself we should
always
be i love that
to be better
and that improve
or change to helping others
getting to a better self if i can and i
decided to take several years at least
to do that gain experience
and
not not just inspire maybe inspire other
people
you know
question is more about other people than
myself currently i believe
very cool well this last question is
going to be
back back to yourself but but i love
your perspective on on the other people
and it's three three words you would use
to describe yourself
oh that's the
mba question
when you want to get in
okay i would say the first one is duct
tape and it was a nickname given to me
by
by a good friend
and that's part of my role in my social
life
i'm
in charge of getting everyone to meet
each other and keep in touch
but daily activity
takes a lot of effort and time but i
don't see it like that i just really
enjoy
getting everyone together
i think the other world is honest
and
i'm just i i usually just say what's on
my mind
without
i don't get embarrassed
i try to keep it real and
maybe write a dark song about it
and the third world will be something
like improving improvement
just talked about it not only me
people around me
the
world amazing shy hopefully one day
no problem
whenever this was fantastic
thank you i really appreciate the time
and the energy
and and checking yourself
in
to know that you're being the right
person for the others next to you i
think that's hugely important
thank you very much
thank you
[Music]